Let's pick up on our color from the four to
five area code.
Who's calling today from four to five?
Uh, Hey David.
Uh, this is per kid or from Everett?
Washington.
How are you?
Hello.
I'm well, thank you.
Um, well my main question is, uh, everybody
has been paying attention to the fact that
he was held the, the $400 million before he
called the Ukrainian president, right.
To demand some investigations into Joe Biden
and his son.
But at the end of this supposedly transcript,
which is just a memorandum of notes of the
phone call was released.
He, he, he, he, they should have not so veiled
threat, which said you have many assets.
He said, you have many assets.
I have many friends in the Ukraine.
I mean it's like, it's like basically coming
out and saying if you don't comply we'll freeze
your assets.
I mean, I don't know if you've noticed that
the press has been completely ignoring.
Well listen, it's still, it's still early
and we're still going through it.
But listen it, there is no question that that
phone call was the culmination of something
that had started long before.
So you have, as I said, you have to go into
it understanding that it's not going to be
one phone call.
Even if we had a word for word transcript,
it would not tell the entire picture, number
one, and there would be all sorts of references
to things that we would not fully understand
because there is so much lead up to it.
So of course of, I mean listen to you, right?
It's exactly what we predicted.
Hello?
Okay.
I guess we lost him all.
Alright.
That does it for phone calls for today.
I do [inaudible] apologize to everybody I
didn't get to, but I will be streaming on
Twitch tonight.
If you want another opportunity to call in
twitch.tv/david Pakman.
We will take a quick break and be back with
more right after this